con vientos de hasta 240 kilómetros por
hora ayuda dejó a su paso destrucción
tumbando árboles dañando edificios como
este hospital
ayuda dejó sin electricidad a toda nueva
orleans y otras áreas en luisiana y
misisipí dejando a más de un millón de
residentes en la oscuridad
desplegaremos nuestras fuerzas para
evitar que ocurran robos y garantizar la
seguridad de los ciudadanos y sus
propiedades algunos residentes trataron
de blindar sus hogares con la esperanza
de permanecer sanos y salvos adentro
otros abandonaron áreas en riesgo
buscando refugio la devastación mortal
causada por el huracán katrina
exactamente hace 16 años estuvo presente
en la memoria de todos solo queremos
irnos rápido para poner a los niños a
salvo el pronóstico indicaba que aida se
debilitaría rápidamente fuertes lluvias
han elevado los niveles de agua en
alabama con equipos de rescate listos
para tomar acción apenas las condiciones
climáticas les permitan despegar
las autoridades dicen que han hecho todo
lo que pueden hacer para evitar una
tragedia del nivel de katrina y evitar
repetir la misma historia pero se han
invertido miles de millones de dólares
más de 14 mil millones en nuestro
sistema de protección de diques tenemos
más tecnología y ciencia sobre estos
avances
las autoridades están monitoreando los
centros de salud en el estado miles de
pacientes por kobe 19 100 hospitalizados
y muchos no pudieron ser evacuados ya
que no hay un lugar seguro para
enviarlos